c'est hervé marseille bonjour monsieur
le sénateur centriste sénateur des
hauts-de-seine qui est notre invité
politique ce matin et bienvenue sur ce
plateau
j'aurais fait marseille tout d'abord
bien sûr cette affaire ben alla vous
êtes président du groupe centriste et
membre de la commission de lois vous
avez donc à ce titre
interrogé auditionné par deux fois
alexandre elle a ainsi que vincent kraz
est ce que le sénat doit saisir la
justice pour parjure après ces nouvelles
révélations
écoutez d'abord il faut établir la
vérité puisque là on nous livre des
informations
d'ailleurs c'est la presse une seconde
fois qui livrent des informations la
justice et est saisie mais tout ça
devient pitoyable je veux dire c'est un
feuilleton qui n'en finit pas on voit
que monsieur benalla était au service du
président de la république on ne pouvait
imaginer qu'il était au service du pays
en fait il était là pour se servir on
s'aperçoit qu'il a menti il a refusé de
répondre à la commission lorsqu'il est
venu la dernière fois et donc il faut
maintenant qu on évalue les choses au
sein de la commission pour savoir s'il
faut saisir la justice ou pas mais
précisément est ce que vous allez c'est
à l'âge de 6 est ce que vous allez faire
un signalement au parquet c'est ce que
l'elysée a déjà fait dans cette affaire
le parquet on a vu par exemple que sur
la sphère des passeports ya pas eu de
suite
d'ailleurs il s'en ait prévalu en disant
il ya eu un article 40 j'ai toujours mes
passeport je passe comme je veux les
frontières la justice ne m'a pas
condamné qu'est ce qui se cache selon
vous derrière toute cette affaire
alexandre belle à la télé j'en sais
strictement rien c'est la dérive de
quelqu'un qui
est ce que c'est une dérive personnelle
est ce que c'est une affaire d'état est
ce que c'est clairement des
dysfonctionnements au plus haut niveau
de l'état
qu'est ce qui se cache dans cette
affaire écoutez je suis pas juge
d'instruction je suis pas juge tout
court ça fait six mois que vous
additionnez les principaux acteurs de de
cette affaire égouttez je pense d'abord
que en france il ya d'autres sujets de
préoccupation que monsieur benallal on
voit qui a une fracture sociale il ya
des gens qui vend par discute tous les
jours pour voir comment on peut
améliorer leur situation leur pouvoir
d'achat
on a une situation européenne terrible
au plan mondial c'est identique et on
est obligé de se pencher sur le cas de
monsieur benalla qui se gèlent et hier
est tous fiers d'avoir été à l'origine
de deux commissions parlementaires qui
se sent dans l'impunité qui se prévaut
du soutien du président écoutez tout ça
est vraiment très dommageable pour
l'image de notre pays mais ça révèle
néanmoins des dysfonctionnements graves
au plus haut sommet de l'état
bien sûr c'est d'ailleurs le rôle de la
commission sénatoriale qui a mis en
valeur j'allais dire son travail et
heureusement qu'elle est là
heureusement qu'elle est là j'observe
que l'assemblée nationale elle a renoncé
à voir votre rapport sera publié dans
coin tant il est en cours de rédaction
je pense qu'il va s'enrichir des
derniers événements et peut-être le
président baba t-il vouloir procéder à
quelques auditions parce que je rappelle
que la commission normalement a terminé
ses travaux officiellement le 23
donc à titre personnel en revanche le
président n'est plus une commission
d'enquêté plus une commission 1,4 mais
peut toujours écrire demander des
informations il peut toujours avoir des
relations si la nouvelle audition il n'y
aura plus prestation de serment
absolument mais il peut toujours
questionné ou rester avec ma mère et ma
soeur